originally when we started studying
pegasus in 2016
a target would have to click on a link
sent via sms in order to facilitate the
infection of the phone
if you didn't click on the link the
phone wouldn't get infected and wouldn't
be able to be
monitored but around 2017 or 2018
nso group appears to have released a
major update to the pegasus system
which allows governments to hack into
phones with a so-called
zero-click technique this means the
target does not need to click on
anything
they don't need to take any action their
phone could be sitting on a table
one minute it's fine the next minute
it's hacked and once it's hacked
the government can access everything on
the phone they can get
messages they can turn on the microphone
and listen into conversations happening
near the telephone
they can take pictures through the
camera they can take passwords
contacts track gps location basically
anything you
can do as the owner of the phone or you
can see the operator of the spyware can
do or see
a major hub for this technology is
israel so the israeli government has for
many years
encouraged the development of a local
cyber industry including
companies like nso group as well as
other companies that sell similar tools
like candy roo which we published an
investigation on last week
and this whole ecosystem of companies
it's not just like there's one
bad apple company that's selling to
repressive governments who are then
using it against journalists it's a
systemic problem with the whole industry
and i think there needs to be regulation
and action
from the israeli ministry of defense and
the israeli government as well as
governments around the world
but most prominently in israel there
needs to be action by the government to
bring the entire
industry under greater control
you